[Música]
[Aplausos]
es una antigua y divertida tradición que
atrae a miles de personas cada año
una multitud exaltada maquillada y
disfrazada que pide que les lancen
Pescado
este solo uno de los alegres misterios
del carnaval de dunkerque
para entender mejor este evento que
enloquece a toda una región seguimos a
Pascal uno de los organizadores
Sería bueno que los tambores mayores
estuvieran a los lados mañana en el
salón de espectáculos de dunkerque se
celebrará el baile del gato negro que
marca el inicio del carnaval Pascal
están por mayor uno de los líderes de la
banda de él dependerá en gran medida que
el baile salga bien no debemos
equivocarnos en nada Cómo se siente la
noche antes del carnaval mal
muy mal con mariposas en el estómago y
todo eso Pero va a salir bien
[Música]
solo quedan unas horas de ensayo antes
de que 10.000 carnavaleros lleguen a la
ciudad
Mientras tanto los habitantes de
dunkerque les dan los últimos retoques a
sus disfraces
Isabel maquilla a su mamá Marcel
mientras su nieta florín las observa
para ellas la tradición de asistir al
carnaval ha pasado de madres a hijas
durante generaciones el carnaval es una
gran parte de nuestras vidas desde que
empezamos a prepararnos nos emocionamos
mucho y dos días antes estamos saltando
como pulgas
no podemos quedarnos quietas
se me hace un nudo en la garganta
nosotras lloramos créame que lloramos
es casi media noche hora de lanzamiento
oficial del carnaval Pascal se pone su
uniforme de tambor mayor solo la
chaqueta pesa casi un kilo
se une a su banda
y entra a la pista
[Música]
finalmente puede darle inicio al baile y
liberar dunkerque
aquí el principio de sencillo la
multitud baila salta y gira alrededor de
la banda y entre todos ellos la abuela
la hija y la nieta van disfrazadas de
bebé
[Música]
increíble estoy tan feliz de estar aquí
es una locura el carnaval es la
identidad misma de dunkerque y así ha
sido desde el siglo XVII y los tiempos
del héroe local el corsario francés
jean-bar por aquel entonces Los
pescadores de dunker que se embarcaban
rumbo a Islandia durante seis meses para
pescar bacalao y no se sabía si todos
regresarían por eso sus jefes les
pagaban la mitad del sueldo por
adelantado para que se divirtieran y
festejaran antes de irse así nació el
carnaval vamos vamos la banda no nos va
a esperar después del baile del gato
negro Marcel vuelve a ponerse su disfraz
porque la temporada de carnaval dura más
de dos meses su momento Cumbre son las
troas tres días de desfiles
multitudinarios por las calles
a veces uno va enganchado del brazo de
alguien y es un abogado todos tenemos lo
mismo en mente divertirnos y olvidar
nuestras preocupaciones
los disfraces el maquillaje y los
paraguas forman parte del folclor del
carnaval de dunquerque al igual que el
alboroto Así que cuidado no es para
débiles es muy físico
ponemos a los hombres más grandes al
frente para mantener a los carnavaleros
atrás
los llamamos el gran alboroto sin
alboroto es solo un desfile y no nos
gustan los desfiles lo que sí les gusta
es disfrazarse de mujer una tradición
que empezó hace tres siglos cuando Los
Pescadores que habían dejado sus maletas
en los barcos antes de su gran fiesta de
despedida tenían que ponerse la ropa de
sus esposas es una época para nosotros
la gente de dunkerque una pausa sí la
calle nos pertenece
nuestro tambor mayor Pascal llega para
poner orden a la multitud de
carnavaleros
a la cabeza del desfile inicia la gran
marcha por dunkerque seguido por decenas
de miles de personas se dirigen hacia la
Plaza de la alcaldía con mucha alegría
llueva truene o relampaguee ahora solo
hace falta un poco de nieve hace sol en
dunker
que imposible claro es famosa por eso
Marcel se asoma al balcón de la alcaldía
para asistir al momento más esperado del
día el lanzamiento de arenques todo un
honor para esta oriunda de dunkerque
es increíble increíble
Qué emoción
hace 35 años que vengo al carnaval 30
disfrazada de bebé
Y esta es la primera vez la primera vez
que gran recuerdo
es extraordinario
miren esa avalancha de gente 20 metros
abajo los asistentes luchan por atrapar
un arenque algo muy simbólico para todos
ellos mi abuelo y mi bisabuelo los
pescaban en Islandia son los mejores
el aire festivo familiar la gente abre
sus puertas Ok está lloviendo hace un
clima feo pero son tan cálidos
bien hecho norteños sigan así
la calidez de toda una región resumida
en un carnaval y cada año se repite para
el gran placer de los habitantes de
dunkerque
[Música]